tu allais prendre
son état exerce ce métier depuis une
quinzaine d'années une terre d'argile
d'une grande finesse appelée faïence
blanche lui sert de matière première
pour faire naître de ses mains de
précieux objets d'art d'une grande
diversité de la tortue miniature au
luminaire et autres pots elle partage
avec nous les gestes subtils et
l'imagination qui exigent cette
profession
j'ai commencé la poterie la
commercialisation d'un peu près avec des
animaux siffleurs
en 84 c'était bon c'était peut-être des
animaux moins sophistiqués mais il y
avait toute une gamme les escargots bon
toujours les enfants c'était à l'origine
des signes aux enfants parce que j'avais
beaucoup de mal à commercialiser de ce
que je fabriquais et je faisais des
expositions à l'époque et j'avais du mal
j'étais très mal à l'aise et en trouvant
ce petit ces petits objets sifflore
j'avais le public des enfants et c'était
bien agréable ça me donnait du courage
et ça a été le pied dans la
commercialisation parce que fabriquer
c'est bien mais vendre aussi c'est bien
il faut et je crois que c'est ce qui est
peut-être plus difficile pour l'artisan
aussi c'est commercialiser
il faut être sûr de soi il faut on a
toujours des fois on est pas trop sûr
surtout quand on commence on n'est pas
sûr de soi et on dévalorise un petit peu
sans ces objets c'est ce qu'on fabrique
alors ça c'est de la terre que j'ai que
j'ai préparé que j'ai passé dans dans
cette machine c'est une boudineuse pour
bien la travailler pour que je puisse
tourner plus aisément que ma terre soit
de bonne qualité je passe ma terre dans
cette machine qui me fait des boudins et
d'où son nom la boudineuse
les poupées cette vidéo
et donc
et ben ça m'évite ce travail ce travail
physique que faisait que font aussi
encore quelques potiers traditionnels là
je prends ma matière et je fais
seulement que des boules je n'ai plus de
travail de malaxage
avant c'était un gros travail c'est
aussi une histoire de temps
bon là la chance non c'est
pas pour cette quantité de terre quand
c'est des gros pots oui il faut il faut
donner mais quand là c'est une petite
boule c'est surtout le geste la façon
dont vous placez les mains qui font que
ça se fait facilement
c'est pas dans la force qu'on l'a c'est
plutôt dans le geste
ça ça demande un peu de temps à avoir
donc le premier temps c'est c'est bien
travailler la terre
la montée
elle va faire une jolie quille et la
descendre
et si je veux faire des choses petites à
ce moment là je ne travaillerai que sur
le sommet de ma mode de terre
pour que ça soit
oh à ce moment-là on rétrécira on fera
une forme toute façon souvent on part
d'une forme cylindrique
en monte et là après on soit on resserre
soit on écarte suivant ce qu'on veut
faire c'est toujours la même technique
quel que soit
les potiens ont chacun son geste un peu
quoi il y a très peu de gestes officiel
moi j'ai pas eu de mettre en tournage
j'ai appris moi-même c'est vrai ici même
à la Réunion
une quinzaine d'années de pratique on
n'a pas besoin de formation forcément
ça facilité énormément de choses
actuellement bon c'était je trouve qu'il
y a 20 ans on pouvait peut-être se
permettre de se former tout seul d'avoir
le temps mais actuellement moi je
conseille aux jeunes de passer par un
apprentissage par une formation par une
école pas c'est un gain de temps
terrible c'est plus rapide c'est plus
rapide bon il y a après une fois qu'on a
les bases rien de toute façon il y a
toujours des choses à découvrir à
rechercher à
il y a toujours des choses à s'enrichir
sur le dans son métier
c'est les circonstances de la vie qui
ont fait que ça se fasse aller pour mais
bon c'est un endroit aussi qui
il y a 20 ans voulait être un centre
artistique un centre
touristique artisanale
bon ça ça a beaucoup dévié
il y a beaucoup de visiteurs il y a des
visiteurs on a on a quand même beaucoup
de gens qui qui connaissent les pros le
bouche à oreille et puis bon on est dans
des guides touristiques dans dans le
Guide du Routard
et donc on a on a une clientèle locale
qui nous amène régulièrement les gens
l'extérieur et
on a les clientèle de passage les
touristes les vrais
c'est une équipe de trois oui vous
travaillez ensemble vous faites
exactement les mêmes choses c'est le
travail à la chaîne
on a on a un peu nos spécialités mais on
est polyvalent aussi bon je sais c'est
vrai que dans l'atelier je suis par
exemple la seule à tourner
madame Ariel ça serait la spécialiste
des dessins des cocotiers
voilà je tourne un peu pour vous voilà
et comme ça je peux je peux recommencer
par exemple si je veux faire un
couvercle je vais pas tourner un couvert
tout ça je vais tourner mon couvercle
comme ça dans ce sens là
et là il va y avoir un deuxième temps de
travail
on essuie toujours la boue on essaye de
sortir l'objet
plus propre possible pour pas qu'il est
trop de travail voilà et ce couvercle il
sera travaillé dans un second temps
justement sur ce Tour là je réserve à ça
dans ce sens là de savoir combien
d'objets vous faites à peu près par jour
si vous
si je tourne je peux tourner une
cinquantaine une centaine de pièces mais
quand je
suis bien rare que je tourne sans pièce
par jour mais j'ai une journée de
travail j'ai une semaine de décoration
derrière
pour pour une journée de tournage j'ai
facilement 8 jours de travail derrière
avec les filles oui je conçois pas du
tout les autres petits comme de la
concurrence la concurrence elle est pas
là la concurrence elle est dans les
objets importés
le nombre le problème c'est les
soi-disant artisans qui
qui produisent ça qui importe ça alors
ça c'est terrible pour nous on peut pas
on peut pas concurrencer donc ce sont
des objets qui ont été empilés les uns
sur les autres pour mettre pour faire
cuire la première cuisson on met
beaucoup de choses dans le four on
superpose bon comme c'est des objets qui
sont qui sont fragiles lorsque l'on met
on peut les superposer quand même mettre
les petits objets dans les objets un peu
plus gros et donc ça c'est la première
cuisson l'objet est cuit c'est à dire
qu'il sonne il doit il doit bien
raisonner et à ce moment là on va faire
un petit dépoussiérage et on va mettre
les couleurs on a on a choisi cette
terre blanche pour pouvoir justement
travailler les couleurs avoir toute une
gamme de couleur on a fait des essais
sur des terres rouges et les couleurs ne
ressortent pas aussi bien donc comme on
est dans une île de couleur ça sera de
la couleur qui aura dessus
là c'est une cuisson qui monte à 1020
degrés il faut 8 heures de monter en
température et 24 heures de
refroidissement vous pouvez toucher
c'est encore chaud ça c'était ça s'est
arrêté hier matin
là là ce sont c'est une cuisson qui
monte à
960 960 980
la cuisson aussi est en 8 heures et donc
autant de temps pour refroidir 24 heures
et c'est
par cette magie de cette cuisson que les
couleurs vont se fixer et se révéler
aussi
donc la première étape le biscuit ce
qu'on appelle le biscuit il y a des amis
la dernière cuisson les paillages donc
il y a des
piliers avec des plaques d'enfournement
pour faire des étagères à l'intérieur là
aucun objet ne doit se toucher un tout
doit être séparé donc ça fait des
enfants non beaucoup plus aériens après
le dépoussiérage on fait un
débarbouillage un barbouillage c'est à
dire qu'on va passer la couleur sur
l'écran de
surfaces pour pour faire des fonds